it was a very tough night of election
results for the democrats and a major
victory for the republicans in virginia
let's start there republican glenn
younkin beat democrat terry mcauliffe
for governor president biden won that
state very easily one year ago today in
new jersey the governor's race is still
too close to call at this hour democrat
phil murphy was expected to win very
easily this is not good news for
president biden who returned overnight
from a trip to the g20 summit and the
u.n climate conference in europe ed
o'keefe has been covering all of this
and joins us from tysons virginia ed
depending on your point of view you're
either in the fetal position or you were
still celebrating was quite a night good
morning to you
good morning gail that's a good way to
put it this is definitely not the
results democrats were hoping for but it
is dreams come true for republicans if
you had any doubt that every vote
matters look at what's going on in
virginia or sorry new jersey let's start
there a big deep blue state where the
margins right now are razor thin
here in virginia first time candidate
glenn younkin will be the first
republican governor elected in a dozen
years all of this big warning signs for
democrats and a virtual rejection of the
biden agenda for the lack of progress on
it so far
together
we will change the trajectory of this
commonwealth
in closely watched virginia republican
glenn younkin came out on top in the
governor's race delivering a decisive
blow to the democratic party voters said
jobs in the economy were top issues
facing the state as a mom as a health
care professional that makes decent
income i am struggling followed by
education with a little more than half
of voters saying parents should have a
lot of say in what's taught in schools a
main theme of younkin's campaign we're
gonna embrace our parents not ignore
them we're gonna press forward with a
curriculum that
includes listening to parents input
democrat terry mcauliffe lost ground in
cities and suburbs that the president
won last year he didn't concede but
acknowledged changes in his state but
folks if i said long ago this is a
different state
when ralph and i were elected eight
years ago we have made our state open
and welcoming but the fight continues
then there's new jersey where governor
phil murphy is staying positive in an
unexpectedly tight race against
republican jack chiararelli we're all
sorry that tonight could not yet
be the celebration we wanted it to be
but as i said when every vote is counted
and every vote will be counted we hope
to have a celebration murphy ran on his
record managing the pandemic while she
had a rally focused on the economy and
education some early polls had murphy
ahead by up to double digits making the
razor thin margins a major
disappointment for democrats and
possibly a blueprint for republicans
looking ahead i'm convinced that
together we can fix this stake
we can fix it
[Applause]
and make no mistake about it the 2022
campaign cycle begins this morning and
you better believe the candidates all
across the country in both parties will
be looking at the results in these
states for clues about how you might be
able to win next year democrats in
congress especially will be scratching
their heads and wondering what they need
to do next as the biden agenda stalls
you should expect tony plenty of finger
pointing in washington today over what
went wrong